como prenden tus hijos en educación a
distancia hoy te presentamos khan
academy planeta de mí es una reconocida
plataforma educativa en línea con
presencia en 190 países disponible en 45
idiomas y con más de 105 millones de
usuarios en khan academy tus hijos
pueden potenciar sus aprendizajes
completamente gratis aquí formarán parte
de una comunidad de aprendizaje junto a
sus compañeros y maestros con el mismo
interés de aprender y compartir
xavier tica enacal es una de las
plataformas que el ministerio de
educación promueve dentro de la
estrategia aprende en casa
la meta de mi complemento en las clases
de matemáticas para reforzar los
aprendizajes de tus hijos en casa usando
computadoras tablets o celulares
pero sabes qué recursos ofrecen khan
academy khan academy ofrece dos tipos de
recursos no teórico y el otro práctico
el teórico está orientado a la
comprensión del tema por ello contiene
artículos y vídeos acorde al grado de
estudio de tu hijo el recurso práctico
presenta un conjunto de diversos
ejercicios en un panel de aprendizaje
personalizado el cual propicia que tu
hijo aprenda a su propio ritmo y de
manera autónoma dentro y fuera de la
clase
para lograr los aprendizajes previstos
del año escolar de tus hijos
canet a demi ha organizado y alineado
sus contenidos al currículo nacional de
educación básica del pelo asimismo los
maestros pueden crear clases en la
plataforma asigna tareas y acompañar el
progreso de tus hijos de manera remota
en este contexto de educación a
distancia contar con una plataforma
donde tus hijos aprenden reciben
retroalimentación inmediata y pueden ver
sus propios avances resulta de gran
ayuda
quieres conocer cómo funciona accede con
tu hijo a la plataforma ingresando a ese
punto
khan academy punto o hereje inicia
sesión con el usuario y la clave de tu
hijo brindados por el maestro o cree en
una cuenta nueva de forma muy sencilla
una vez que han accedido a la cuenta
dirígete al menú vertical está al lado
izquierdo y da un clic en la opción
tareas de la clase correspondiente
aparecerán al lado derecho de la página
la lista de tareas asignadas por el
maestro
es
disponibles en la parte superior
izquierda para que tu hijo comienza a
aprender de una forma interactiva y
divertida no te olvides de felicitar a
tus hijos cada vez que logre los
objetivos propuestos en clase así como
motivarlos y apoyarlos en esta nueva
etapa aprovechemos al máximo este
recurso gratuito hoy que tus hijos
cuentan con canacar
si te interesa conocer más sobre cómo
apoyar a tus hijos
usando esta plataforma visita sigamos
aprendiendo puntos
khan academy punto o elegir juntos
podemos lograr que la educación no pare
[Música]